good morning and welcome david horowitz
is the founder and president of the
david horowitz Freedom Center an
institution devoted to defend the
principles of individual freedom the
rule of law private property limited
government and academic freedom he's
also the editor for front page magazine
and the founder of students for academic
freedom Horowitz has authored numerous
books including radical son
indoctrination mu and the professor's
the 101 most dangerous academics he
earned a Bachelor of Arts in English
from Columbia University and a master's
degree in English literature at the
University of California Berkeley today
he will be speaking on rules for
radicals what constitutional
conservatives should know about Saul
Alinsky please join me in welcoming
David Horvath
you
Oh morning I've been not asked not to
speak too long so I brought along small
notes what constitutional conservatives
should don't about Saul Alinsky and
radicals conservative a conservative
outlook the linking of constitutional
and conservative is also a clue is
rooted in the past
conservatives are concerned with who who
we have been and therefore who we are
and therefore what it takes to govern us
well and to create a reasonably
productive and reasonably harmonious a
harmonious almost sounds like a
left-wing word right there
a little delusional societies and
therefore conservatives are concerned
about principles and inherent in
principles are limits limits the way you
have to limit human behavior and the way
you have to limit the human beings that
limit us the government it's about
that's why it's about limited limited
government for conservatives the root
cause of social problems is us that's
the basic orientation of a conservative
outlook radicals of a completely
different orientation they are oriented
towards the future and of course there
is no the future they are oriented
towards an imaginary future a future in
which they can put everything into place
as they see fit
ah and which is a form of or would be a
form of human perfection if we realized
they radical speak of social justice as
they're as if there could ever be such a
thing if human beings are the source of
our problems they're not going to solve
them are they
because of radical and and I don't think
if you have been a conservative or your
life you can probably not would be a
huge effort and I've found a few
conservatives who we want to take the
time out to do it to put themselves in
the you know leftist mindset a radical
mindset and and see the way they see the
world I'm often asked by conservatives
how how can they hate America was a
great place how could how can they not
see that in the Middle East Israel is a
democracy it's tolerant as a million
Muslim Arabs living there with more
rights than all the Muslim and any other
in any Muslim country and on the other
side you have religious fanatics who
want to purge the world of infidels how
is it difficult to know which side to be
on and the answer is that of course
radicals don't see the reality in the
practical boots on the ground reality
either in Israel or the United States
they're not looking at the wonderful
privileges that we have as Americans
thanks to the founders and the
constitutional framework they created
but they're looking at is America versus
heaven
what we lose we lose the so the radical
for the Marx actually in the eighteenth
Brumaire
quotes good as Memphis Tov Elise saying
everything that exists deserves to
perish that is the mentality of the
radical everything should be swept away
so that we can create a world where
there's no no inequality how do you do
that no inequality no racism no sexism
no homophobia no poverty no war that's
the radicals fantasy and that's how they
judge the present and that judge
everything negatively for the radical
oriented towards the future there are no
limits human potential is good and it's
locked in by all the oppressive
structures as they see them oppressive
structures of the social order they have
contempt for structure and process you
might ask yourself how somebody like
Barack Obama who has been the
beneficiary of all of America's
greatness and goodness
it came from difficult family beginnings
the Harvard became President of the
United States how he could have spent
his adult years as a lawyer for acorn
which is an organization convicted of
greatest election frauds in the history
of the United States well it's because
if you're radical you think elections
are fraud to begin with so by committing
fraud you're just correcting a fraud the
Louis all Linsky Saul Alinsky was a
Chicago radical who came to adulthood in
it 30s he was a sociology graduate
student at the University of Chicago and
did studies of the Al Capone II mob and
adopted as his T as his teacher Frank
Nitti Frank Nitti was a guy that Kevin
Costner threw off the top of the
building it was then enforcer I've said
Frank Nitti was my teacher what's what's
all in skiis contribution to the radical
assault on our culture in our society
was was this he was a fellow traveler
that is of the communists that is he did
not he fellow travelers were leftists
who endorsed the goal the fantasy future
and
that if you have the if you believe in
the fantasy of a socialist future then
you condemn America and capitalist
societies as species of hell he shared
that view but fellow travelers didn't go
along with the means he thought the
Communists were too dogmatic and too
rigid he was what what you call an anti
anti-communist which means he was
offended and I American and I Western
democracy anti judeo-christian and so
forth he was also very critical of the
new left I was part of the new left and
I of all the bad things that you know
about the new left the left of the 60s
and I'm written with Peter Collier a
book called destructive generation which
is my view of that left it had one
redeeming Grace we said what we were
about well you know we want revolution
and we want it now you know we want
America to lose in Vietnam we said these
things and Alinsky thought we were nuts
for saying that and we we had slogans up
against the wall the sky's the limit off
the pigs right I all the bad things I
did in the sixties I I never said off
the pigs but that was the attitudes
towards the police political power grows
out of the barrel of a gun
and Olinsky said what you're doing when
you say those things is you're
telegraphing to people what you're going
to do what you want to do and they're
going to understand that you're a threat
and
that's bad so the when Olinsky said in
Olinsky gives an example from one of his
heroes which is Lenin where Lenin Lenin
said that we want oh we want the ballot
but when we win the elections then we'll
have the guns and it'll be a different
story
Olinsky said you don't say political
power grows out of the barrel of gun
when the other side has the guns I
actually had a confrontation like that
in the 60s with Michael Lerner the
editor of t cont when he came to me in
semi hysterical mode saying you have to
buy a gun David and I said to Michael if
you could tell me one situation and
where it's the police or the military
against us and we win I'll consider it
alright Solomon you have to buy a
handgun for assassinations Michael
Lerner is an unreconstructed leftist and
posing as a rabbi these days so
olinsky's really the main thrust of the
Olinsky Olinsky doctrine is deception
why you don't tell people what your
agendas are when you're when you have to
win them when you're winning them over
you tell them well and the more
government controlled health care would
be bad but completely private would be
bad so you know we have to do the
reasonable thing and we'll bring
Republicans and Democrats together and
we're not the red states of the blue
states for the United States all the
things that Barack Obama
said you snooker people Barack Obama is
an not only an alinsky disciple but an
Alinsky trainee when he came out of
Colombia his first job was with an
elinsky organization he went through the
Alinsky training he was the lawyer for
another Alinsky organization acorn
that's who he is when he says community
organizer I'm a community organizer he
means I am a follower of Saul Alinsky
because that's what's Olinsky was it was
community organizing is organizing an
army and that's olinsky's term not mine
I put it all all these things in this
little a little booklet it's organizing
a power base the the idea is to create
the power to do what you want
with no clear idea of what you want I
will get into what they want but there
really is there has never been there
were socialist plans French a Frenchman
named Fourier had a plan that were these
utopian communities in the 19th century
and they all failed Marx was smarter he
said you can't can't have a blueprint
and since Marx there are no serious
radicals have attempted to devise a plan
so their their plan really is that
everything exists deserves to perish
they're playing
if you get me to make a revolution you
know there are two sides of it one is
taking down the old system and the other
is creating the new no attention is
given to creating the new so it's really
a form of nihilism
that's what radicalism is about that's
what olinsky's book rules for radicals
that the original title was rules for
revolution which is why I used it in
this
the booklet I did revolutionaries only
understand destruction then there it
well am stay in destruction and
deception which is them one of the means
para one of the means of destruction
olinsky's idea then was you pose as we
called it in the 60s boring from within
you posed as a liberal I was appalled
when in the early 70s it was really
during the McGovern campaign all my
communist friends all the people who
like Tom Haven who advocated liberated
zones in America wanted guerrilla
warfare and American streets suddenly
appeared as Democrats and liberals in
1971 1972 because we hated liberals and
that was another good thing about the
new left that's what kept it smaller and
prevented it from ever getting to the
White House because we despised liberals
because we felt that liberals were
co-opting would co-opt you into the
system but Alinsky got very close to
Bobby Kennedy became part of the war on
poverty program and financed his radical
operations from taxpayer funds I I was
people just asked me when I cease to be
a leftist who funded you Moscow Havana
well I'm sure there was money from
Moscow and Havana but that's not who
funded us who funded some funds the left
is you through through taxpayer dollars
people were outraged when when acorn was
exposed because they got fifty three
million dollars remember
53 million dollars in federal funds
starting in 1994 now ring a bell 1994
that's when Republicans took over the
house and the purse strings Republicans
funded ACORN made it the largest radical
organization in the history of the
country and that's mainly because
conservatives I don't know how to put
this lightly but it's just not paying
attention and and I you know I changed
the mission statement of my centers
it sounded like with all conservative
organizations sound liked it very
positive and good the principles of a
kind of of constitutional principles
private property rule of law that's all
well and good but we're in a war as I
will get to in a moment so my Center is
now called I have its mission is the
defense of free societies whose cultural
and economic foundations are being
attacked by an international left that's
the reality were in and and I would like
conservatives move 10% of the positive
approach to a certain negative one where
there's a threat here and it's an
internal threat that has to be met a
prototypical Alinsky I is the former
green jobs czar who is now part of the
brains trust of the Democratic Party Van
Jones he's with the Center for American
Progress here in Washington which is
John Podesta's operation and is the
brains trust of the Democratic Party
Van Jones was a vocal self-described
communist and this was not in the 1930s
but but in the 1990s and into 2000 he
belonged to a Maoist revolutionary
Vanguard party that is modeled on the
Bolsheviks called storm there were
Maoists and then he had a conversion
experience to Alinsky ISM and what he
said how he described it was I prefer I
given up the cheap satisfactions of the
radical pose for the deep satisfactions
of radical ends so if you well he's such
a smooth talker now that beg Whitman the
Republican candidate for governor in
California saying his praises thought
that he was just a wonderful person and
that that's because she had no idea who
he was one of the I think probably the
best thing that I've done in the quarter
of a century that I've devoted to
atonement for my youthful sins is
creating an encyclopedia of the left on
the web which explains exactly what
people like man Jones are about you must
always remember that the slogan of the
Communist Party in my youth which was
when Joseph Stalin was alive was peace
jobs and democracy
how many people have seen the invasion
of the body snatchers that film was made
the original film was made during the
50s and was about the Communists but it
could be about anybody not anybody but
it could be about a lot of people I call
themselves liberal today they're pod
people basically the the new left there
was it actually was an issue of SDS
new left notes there was an article by a
an SDS radical in the 60s which said the
issue is never the issue the issue is
always the revolution what that means is
for and this is a core principle of Glin
schism that the the the way you view
issues is always instrumental does it
further the revolution you may have
noticed you may have noticed that even
though there are something like 600
women's studies programs which are
basically political parties in the
university organizing for a feminism
there are no protests over the
unbelievable abuse and oppression of
women in the Muslim world none I am here
cially a courageous warrior against the
Islamic oppression of women I asked her
I bribed sort last month in Philadelphia
I asked her if she's ever been invited
to a Women's Studies department to talk
about the oppression of women in Islam
and she said once but it turned out that
it was a an American Enterprise
Institute benefactor
who was either a trustee at UC San Diego
or whatever he was and got her one talk
one talk in all these years and that's
because the issue is never the issue
feminists are not about women they're
part of the left they're about
destroying American capitalism or
imperialism if they would prefer to call
it and they see the Muslim world and the
jihad against us however much they may
deplore this or that tactic as a
movement for liberation from American
oppression the issue is never the issue
the issue is always the revolution and
therefore you should understand that
green jobs is not about the environment
what green jobs is about it was having a
communist Van Jones weak root an army of
leftists at taxpayer expense and it
believe me it's still about that and the
health care system it's not about
delivering quality health care the Obama
care it's about control of everybody's
life and also putting people on the
payroll
Alinsky
I'm actually there was a one of the
articles I used as a resource was a New
Republic article by Ryan Lisa who
interviewed Olinsky trainers and people
who had been trained by alinsky himself
and they described to him how idealistic
people because the seduction of the left
is things you know wonderful social
justice peace harmony peace jobs and
democracy just you know so you get a lot
of people in who are salivating to that
Bell what those bells and Alinsky is to
say why a community organizer why do you
want to be a community organizer and the
answers would you know to make the world
the better place to whatever in racism
and he would scream that the person who
said that said no you want to be a
community organizer to get power that's
what it's all about power this is the
olinsky's rules for revolution is a
nihilistic tract Machiavellian and
nihilistic it's everything that one
would regard as evil from an ethical any
ethical standpoint but of course it's
all redeemed by the fantasy future and
that this is what the left is about but
Alinsky is a particularly frank
expression of this Estella lists
actually thought that they are you know
a planned economy they had vague ideas
enough about the about the future but it
was much more structured in
self-respecting than Alinsky ISM what
organizes the alinsky radical is that
hatred of the so-called haves America is
a have society there are haves and
have-nots this is the mark this it's
just another way of formulating the
Marxist idea of a ruling class well but
if you think about America I mean I I
think that's something like seventy
percent of the millionaires in this
country are first-generation which means
they made it it's absurd to think of
this as a country of haves and haft of
course there are some people who just
have they were born with it they don't
do anything for it but there are so many
more people with a lot of money who are
investing at all the time creating jobs
creating wealth for everybody the proper
way to think about the divisions of our
societies is the cans and the cannot the
do's and the do nots the Wills
and the will nuts that's what it's about
but if you think about it that way then
that's the end of radicalism the whole
mythology of radical radicalism is
exploded and of course the Solinsky idea
I mean he says that my book will so
radical x' is modeled on Machiavelli's
The Prince which was really should rule
the difference is that my book is about
taking away the power of the haves in
his book is about how the haves can keep
it then where does this reactionary view
of the world as rigidly or society as
rigidly divided into rulers and rule
come from well comes from the communist
Festo which is the most read most
assigned text I don't know this for a
fact but I know this from studying you
know being at 300 universities and
asking questions the most assigned text
in our universities today is the
Communist Manifesto I I've met
innumerable students without to read it
three and four times in different
different classes and you remember what
the Communist Manifesto how it begins
the history of all hitherto existing
societies is the history of class
struggle its slave owners versus slaves
you know I forget the Roman well
whatever it is lords versus serfs and of
course then it becomes capitalists
worship versus wage slaves versus the
proletariat and remarks what the
Communist Manifesto basically says is
that democracy capitalist democracies
are a fraud just what acorn says that
there is an actual ruling class that
rigs elections their wigs elections and
so elections don't really mean anything
and what Marx incited in the communist
manifesto was war civil war since
elections don't mean anything than any
anything is justified in subverting them
and establishing the rule of the pure
and the just vanguard which is which is
the left and alinsky the other aspect of
alinsky ISM the deception in the first
place the don't don't tell people where
you're going
just you know lead them along and I was
thinking of that by the way the other
day with this idiotic NASA pronouncement
well if you want to take America down I
mean you know space technology is
advanced technology it has all kinds of
implications both peaceful and military
so you cut its funding when their
bombers virtually ended the space
program and then you devoted to giving
our technologies to our enemies that's
what that is about so
Alinsky is a really a closet mark system
and so a lot of his book is devoted to
explaining that this is a war the haves
will not give up the imaginary haves
will not give up power peacefully that's
that's a an axiom of the radical outlook
and therefore you conduct a war against
them now the war when you don't have the
guns you don't look to guns as the
solution you look to getting power by
other means and arms in our society it's
getting it through through the ballot
box which they have done and then you
use those means to get to the next step
you always deal and this is an elinsky a
precept you always deal with the
situation you have you know if you're
too radical you will destroy yourself
which is what the you know it's another
beneficent aspect of the 60s now left it
destroyed itself it kept upping we
called it upping the ante so you know
protests in the streets march on the
Pentagon stop the draft and then it was
guerrilla warfare and white mill class
students actually we're not too thrilled
about getting themselves killed in a
guerilla warfare and and so the weather
the weather men which is Obama what do
you call him in mu winces I one of those
who's been persuaded that Billy Ayers
world Obama's book but he certainly was
a strategic comrade and close political
intimate of Obama's through his through
his rise Billy Ayers went off to the
wars but they didn't take very many
people with them they had a few hundred
people out of a new left that could put
on demonstrations with hundreds of
thousands so you you deal with the
situation that you have but you
understand always that it's a war
conservatives look and leftists and see
them as misguided people whom you can
maybe explain if you have enough time to
explain to them but they're just
misguided
they see us as evil they see themselves
as the army of the saints and they see
us as the party of Satan and that's
because mentally they're in a war for a
new world on the other side of the
rainbow so in this war
the ends of course justified the means
and when Alinsky addresses this problem
in just those terms
he has other contempt for the Liberals
of his day who said well I agree with
your ends that should tell you something
about modern liberalism right away I
agree with your ends destroy the system
but I don't like your means and when
Olinsky said was that it's an irrelevant
question means it ends because it should
always be about the particular means to
achieve a particular end but then he
goes on and he has actually a principle
of good get what he calls it but as per
tactical principle which is then in a
war all means are justified a war is
about survival if you if you have the
radical outlook you see it as heaven
versus hell and actually Rose ellipse
looks and burg that was her slogan
socialism or barbarism and if you read
Christopher Hitchens irresistible but
very muddled memoir I mean Rosa
Luxemburg is his heroes that is
Christopher who's wise enough to
understand America's worth saving and is
a a chief really defender of freedom in
the world today nonetheless thinks that
socialism or barbarism is a heroic
slogan so it's a very deeply imprinted
binary in the radical mind if you
believe that around the corner is
healthcare for all food for all shelter
for all of an on and on
and this is the Green Party platform by
the way literally then America is a
horrible place and almost anything you
would do it would be justified or
anything if you believed let's put it a
different way if you believe that you
could bring about the kingdom of heaven
on earth
what crime would you not commit and what
lie would you not tell to do it and
that's why are the great atrocities all
the really great so it's a bad word
monstrous lay at large
atrocities of the last hundred years
have been committed by radicals seeking
a better world
all of them the I will close with this
the because it gets personal for anybody
who's been a conservative and open their
mouths they understand the politics of
personal destruction that is coming
their way
olinsky's biographer who is a great
admirer of olenski's gives an example of
when George HW Bush the first president
Bush I can't remember if he was a you I
think he was a UN representative he had
been the head of the CIA and it was our
ambassador UN ambassador and was
speaking I think it was at Texas A&M and
students wanted to protest his speech
and since he had been with the CIA
everything associated with the Vietnam
War and everything and olinsky's advice
to them was to dress up in as in Ku Klux
Klan outfits and cheer cheer Bush on
now well I mean that tells you about
what Ellen Schism is in a nutshell you
tar and feather stigmatize and
obliterate anybody who disagrees with
you and you know if you've argued that
racial preferences are actually I knew
you all I can see in this audience we
put it very politely discriminatory I
would say racist but discriminatory is
why you will be accused of being a
racist because racism in our context is
a destroyer you are a racist I mean if
you are a racist
you become a nun person you're not
you're drummed out of polite polite
society and it was letting of course I
mean none of this is original it was
Lenin who said that the object of a
political debate is not to defeat the
opponent in an argument but to wipe them
from the face of the earth and you will
notice that the political figures in arm
the fingers in our political life who
have been wiped from the face of the
earth by having said the wrong thing at
any given time are all Republicans and
conservatives if you are a leftist you
can have a prostitution ring run out of
your house
and wind up in control of the American
economy so a constitutional
conservatives have a big task in front
of them I
you're disposed to be reasonable to be
to observe principles and the principles
enjoin you to give the other fellow the
benefit of the doubt to include diverse
opinions and so forth and you're facing
an enemy that wants to destroy you
personally and socially you have to find
out a way to square that circle thank
the good news is that I think we
distributed 400,000 copies of this well
everything I said is really in this
little booklet so that people are Obama
has waked people up and had that long
that's a good it's like that you left
that's the benign part that
conservatives are finally understanding
I spent 20 years in utter frustration
saying the Conservatives stop calling
them liberals they are bigoted they're
intolerant they're on principle yeah and
they want to bring about a socialist
oppressive Leviathan state they're
socialists and now this is my ex DeMint
all Riley but everything conservatives
finally are calling them by their right
names and actually it was Confucius who
said that if you want to restore justice
or establish justice you have to begin
biking calling things by their right
names Jenny
for him the front lines as long as
you've been on the front lines trying to
warn us so thank you for that I want to
ask you if you when surveyed the
environment what gives you hope and you
just alluded to some of it to me it's
the Tea Party the new citizen activist
rising up that is surprising and it's
the Internet and it's the talk radio and
it's the collapse of the mainstream
media all of those are circumstances
that are helping us right now in the
time of our life yes no I agree I spoken
at the at least for tea party events I
think the Tea Party the Tea Parties is
the most exciting development in
conservatism in since I've been aware of
conservatives that that there's nothing
more powerful than that I think it's
getting involved I mean how did we lose
our schools we lost our schools because
conservatives did nothing and it's still
very difficult as you may know I written
four books and I on universities and the
fifth one will be out in the fall
and a very very little support I mean
I've had good support from some
conservative groups again America's
foundation some refuel Republicans
including some members of the Republican
leadership but the Republican Party is
completely asleep on the problem of of
the schools although in Texas there has
been a blip there on the radar a very
exciting one in my view
conservatives complain a lot they're
good at going to complaining well you
know I think of it this way I mean I
love Bill Buckley Bill Buckley wrote a
wonderful book about Yale in 1951 I
think is when God and man and Yale might
have been 52 was published and and and
his idea was that if you put up an
argument and people will I guess buy it
or not but he never created an academic
reform movement the he was the first
president of is I which is now itself
what does that make it almost 60 years
old and is I is a wonderful educational
you know it brings literature of the
students and speakers to campus but it
it has never engaged in academic reform
and in fact there is no well since I
started my academic bill Rights Campaign
there's been two conservative
organizations then that have attempted
to do something but we don't have a
conservative educational reform movement
and our schools are now recruitment and
indoctrination centers for the
Democratic Party and the extreme radical
left so we got a lot of work to do but I
have seen more boy hate this it's such a
California work growth in the
conservative movement and just in terms
of its political understanding that
there's a war on it's not just about
elections it's going on every day and
every every week and every month I'm
more advanced on the conservative front
and that since the election of Barack
Obama and in the preceding twenty or
thirty years that that's my optimism
yeah
mangle this quote plus I understand the
shows you one point says something about
being able to talk a millionaire out of
all this money one day to support
something that he hanging forth on the
next day well actually Lenin said count
on the capitalist to sell you the rope
that will hang them with and Alinsky was
very good at that yeah absolutely and
just let's not forget that Walter
Annenberg a lifelong Republican and
conservative gave 900 million dollars to
the left including 50 million dollars to
Billy Ayers for the purpose of bringing
radical anti-american organizers into
the Chicago Public School System
conservatives wake up and that's
actually the good news little bit
because there is a conservative mass out
there and the conservative organizations
of the conservative movement and it's a
much easier sell than persuading these
religious leftists to change their
religion is to wake up conservatives if
you would just wake up conservatives
will win that's it it's not stop
worrying about I don't know introducing
a Keith Olbermann to sanity or something
don't worry about that it's not
important what's important is the
Conservatives wake up and stop attacking
each other I'm just up to here with the
attacks I'm Glenn Beck for example just
as an example I mean this guy has got a
school on television if you disagree
with that 10 percent of it so what you
know I wish there were more
Glenn Beck's out there stop I I never
see Republican some bloody minded as
they're attacking each other never do
they attack Democrats the way they
attack each other that just is anyway my
question do you think the sorrows know
about mindset okay he's talking about
billionaires that fund the communist
left now here's here's my little
Hollywood story I actually gave up on
now
which will eliminate that or answer the
question gave up on watching the Academy
Awards when Gandhi a boring and
falsifying film Gandhi was not well
anyway go into that um deceptive
propaganda film good fiction no bad
fiction it was boring when that won the
Academy Award over et I said that I'm
not watching anymore
and why did why did Gandhi went over et
because Gandhi was everything that
Hollywood wants to be thin moral and tan
and that's what it gets them it gets
them being you know feeling good about
themselves Soros is a criminal and but
he's he's announced that he aspires to
be the conscience of the world so you
will notice when the Kennedy family was
a right-wing family I mean Jack Kennedy
you know he was a hawk it was a militant
ni communist the hawk on defense for a
capital gains tax cut and a balanced
budget it was only after Bobby thought
that he and Bobby was aspired to be
McCarthy's chief counsel it was only
after he felt that he had got his
brother murdered give with the guilt
that he moved left and it was only after
Teddy Kennedy I mean one of the first
things that Teddy Kennedy did after he
killed that woman at Chappaquiddick was
to give a speech attacking America's war
in Vietnam that's how the Kennedy family
moved left it was to get gain moral
stature actually oh that yeah that's the
accent that's a Fred Thompson joke and
it's a good one which is then Hollywood
is a place where people think that you
can gain in moral stature by getting
next to people in Washington
I have questions once a quick fact
question and what is a question of the
quick fact question is where are the
back issues of heterodoxy available
are they on they should be on the
internet and if they're not and what's
right it should be up on our site you
know we have a complex of sites but
front page should be the door or I had
them put put heterodoxy up there so
there I know there are a lot of issues
and if they not call my office and tell
them that you that I said they said I'll
get to work on it thank you then the
longer question is as we're talking
about the issue is not the issue and you
were talking about acorn it was the baby
wonder is not the same thing going on
with Planned Parenthood funding from the
town government the issue there really
isn't the issue of family planning so an
issue of government control or do you
not or do it could be I mean I I know
that when my mother left she resigned
from as a teacher because they were been
investigated because she was a communist
she immediately got a job with my and
Parenthood because it was run by the
Communists and still this so funding
Planned Parenthood is basically again
funding the left look it's all patronage
it's just like Tammany Hall I mean this
is just patronage system and that's why
you know watch Republican politicians I
mean Schwarzenegger did this in
California but they they'll take on the
unions and they'll you know it'll be
like card check or it'll whatever and
for Republicans it's it's an issue but
for them it's life and death this is
where they live so if you're going to go
after them you better have a big war
chest and you better make it one issue
and not he had for proposition
which is why it went down but but uh
yeah these this is this is these are the
armies on the left and they are you know
where did with which the stimulus money
where'd the trillions of dollars go it
went to state budgets so that all these
bureaucrats in the state systems who are
all going to be Democrats and leftists
don't lose their jobs everybody else is
cutting their budget except for the
states and the cities and that's where
all the obama lion's share the obama
money is gone thank you very much as for
us we have time for one more question
here
Thank You mr. lawless for your talk and
actually undergraduate Hillsdale College
so I wasn't difficult at the public
education system of your friendship but
I have a kind of a temperament question
about the conservative temperament and
talked about how conservatives might to
use reason and appeal moderate and
because we tend to be reasonable as it
goes to demonizing our opponents so how
do we how do we debate without looking
like we are radicals how do we debate
well you know that co-opting their
methods me not that's the sixty-four or
what is it $64,000 question that that
you have to answer I I often say that I
think I think that I've been sent as a
an ex radical to teach conservatives bad
manners but um you know look being you
know having a conservative outlook I
know that that conservatives are not
going to be radicals and that's good but
you know maybe 10% shift you've got to
find a way to do it
I I have to say I think Sarah Palin is
very good at this
you know how are you liking the hope you
change II think I'm naturally so you
find a way but just don't mistake who
your opponent is and don't be
intimidated by them a lot of
conservatives will back off you're going
to have to get a little bloodied and I
think that that's happening I think the
the Tea Party movement is a good example
I what you know I I saw it happening in
my academic campaign I am there was a
film called obsession which was about
the Islamofascist and their jihad
against America and the West and a
student wanted to show it it pays
college and the presidents of the Muslim
Students Association which is an arm of
the Muslim Brotherhood complained and
the president shut it down which
violated their constitutional rights of
a eventually we're allowed to show it
but I am I had an event here in
Washington with the 500 students and at
the event this was in February two years
ago three years ago I said on April now
I'm going to declare I am declaring
right now April 19th Islamofascism
Awareness Day and I will show this film
on a hundred campuses and the minute I
said it I said what did I miss
I couldn't I don't know maybe so I can't
think of an occasion where two
conservative organizations worked in
concert on different campuses now I
actually I've been I've spoken at
Amherst College there are five colleges
within 10 miles of each other near
Amherst now I'm there I am Hearst
College UMass Amherst Smith the others
and they didn't coordinate I mean it's
not like conservative speaker comes in
every week to these schools so no
coordination and that's conservatives if
they see somebody walking alongside them
as oh I got I'm a collectivist I'm a I'm
but I I got a hundred universities to do
it and I did a slam Oh fascism awareness
weeks three four four times and we got
we were able to coordinate a hundred one
hundred campuses and that's a change and
also calling it Islamofascism Awareness
Day you can imagine I mean a
conservative let's brought up to
understand that their reputation is as
important an asset as they have not to
get into you know fights with skunks and
so forth that's that's everybody is
schooled that way and you just go out
for Islamic fascism we're in this week
you're gonna be attacked as racist a
homophobe an islamaphobe etc but the
kids did it and I think that you know
it's a change mentality because of the
war we're at war we've been attacked and
we're going to be you know we're
attacked just an alleged since Obama I
mean there's been all if any of those
other attacks are successful they could
have you know I'm playing exploding over
Detroit or or blowing up crime square
we're in a war and you have to change
your mentality somewhat for the war
there's a lot of conservatives in the
military they know how to fight
just
I just wanted to say that I've actually
had a long kind of relationship with
Hillsdale even though I've never been
today to the campus that bad I can't
remember whether whatever it was
mm I work with Larry Arne Mozilla's our
president onward Connolly's a civil
rights initiative campaign we work
together on that and I have I've done
Hillsdale fundraiser so I'm very
supportive of this institution I hope
all you will be too